President Trump says he is very
confident there will be a corona virus
vaccine by the end of the year he
appeared at the Lincoln Memorial last
night on a Fox News virtual town hall as
he defended his handling of the pandemic
he also sharply increased his estimated
death toll in the u.s. Paula Reid
reports from the White House last week
President Trump said up to 70,000
Americans could die from the corona
virus but last night he increased that
estimate we're gonna lose anywhere from
seventy five eighty to a hundred
thousand people it's a horrible thing
his top health officials say the number
could actually be up to two and a half
times that our projections have always
been between a hundred and two hundred
and forty thousand American lives lost
and that's with full mitigation and us
learning from each other of how the
social distance but the president is
still pushing to reopen the country
are you going to urge the nation's
universities and schools to go back in
September I am I want them to go back we
have to get our country back the
president says the timeline for each
state to reopen will be different but he
suggested some states were even taking
too long
certain states are gonna have to take a
little more time in getting open and
they're doing that some states I think
frankly aren't going fast enough seated
at the Lincoln Memorial mr. Trump was
asked if he was bringing the country
together I think that winning ultimately
is going to bring this country together
I'm shocked that during a crisis it
would be so partisan but he took no
responsibility for the divide blaming
Democrats instead the Democrats the
radical left whatever you would rather
see people I'm gonna be very nice I'm
not gonna say die I'm gonna say we'd
rather see people not get well we are
not partisan combatants we're human
beings
over the weekend a call for unity came
from former President George W Bush in a
video message let us remember how small
our differences are in the face of this
shared threat President Trump took issue
with the former president statements and
lashed out at his silence during
impeachment with the number of deaths
rising and more and more Americans
losing their jobs the president is once
again laying the blame on China my
opinion is they made a mistake they
tried to cover it they tried to put it
out just like a fire you know it's
really like trying to put out a fire
they couldn't put out the fire
president Trump has previously praised
China's handling of this outbreak and
these new claims about transparency come
amid increased criticism of the Trump
administration's handling of this
pandemic over the weekend Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo claimed that China
tried to conceal the extent of this
outbreak while stockpiling medical
supplies last night president Trump said
there will be a very conclusive report
from the US about the origins of this
virus Gale that's very disturbing
information Thank You Paula